chairman okay
thank you very much good afternoon and
welcome to this south east area planning
committee meeting
on wednesday the 5th of august 2020. my
name is councillor michael helm
and i am the vice chairman of this
committee deputising for councillor
richard dewick the chairman
the meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect on
the 4th of april in response to the
covid19 situation
there are just a few housekeeping issues
to run through
first of all please could i ask everyone
present at this meeting to ensure your
microphone remains muted
and your video feed is off when not
addressing the committee
this will reduce background noises and
avoid any unintentional disturbances
this meeting is being hosted remotely
streamed live
and recorded and by being present in the
meeting
you are giving your consent to being
recorded
members and officers during each item
please use the chat function
of the meeting to indicate if you wish
to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating you wish to speak
or that you have to leave the meeting
the chat function should
not be used for questions
for any other purpose please do not use
the raise hands function as this is not
available on all members devices
when speaking and referring to the
agenda papers please ensure your
reference
you reference a page or paragraph number
and lastly
need to delete the meeting at any point
please
make it known using the chat function to
signify that you need to leave the
meeting
now we'll ask officers to take part in
the meeting to introduce themselves
starting with mr lee
mr lee thank you chairman i
am matthew lee lee's specialist place
here at morton district council
michael johnson chairman
my name is michael johnson specialist
development manager
thank you thank you catherine matthews
hello i'm catherine matthews i'm a
specialist in development management
thank you thank you devon
aaron is that correct hey now yeah well
done
good afternoon i'm devon herner a
specialist in development management
thank you thank you louise
good afternoon i'm louise staplehurst
and i'm a specialist in development
management
have we got any other officers present
uh just myself chairman um
bernie casey clark to this afternoon's
meeting thank you chairman
can you please now carry out the roll
call of members to confirm who's in
attendance please thank you
can we have a roll call please burner
sorry i was muted um i will call your
names in alphabetical order members
counselor passenger
good afternoon i'm here good afternoon
mr chairman
thank you councillor beale
i don't think we have council bill with
us and
councillor boyce president
thank you cancer channel
can you hear me yes yeah i i'm i'm just
trying out these headphones
yes i'm present if you need to see me i
can put my camera on there you go i am
here
lovely thank you councillor fluker
present i don't think i'll be able to
use my video because i haven't got any
ball band
yes we can thank you very much
councillor skeens
yep i'm here thanks and counselor stamp
present thank you
thank you berna apologies for absence my
i have apologies for absolutely burner
yes we received apologies for absence
from councillors bell and
dueck i'm afraid they can't do
daytime meetings no minutes it is
recommended the minutes of the meeting
held on the 11th 10th of june the 2020
found on pages 7 to 22
are approved as a true and accurate
record iso move if you wish to second
that motion
please turn on your video unmute your
microphone and state your name now
does anyone want to read raise the
matter at all
no right so they're agreed by ascent are
they chair
yes it looks like it thank you thank you
declarations of interest disclose the
existence of nature of any disclosure
cuny interest
or pecuniary interest or non-pecuniary
interests related to items and business
on the agenda having regard to
paragraphs six to eight inclusive for
the code of conduct for members
members are reminded that they should
also disclose any such interests as soon
as they become aware
should the needs arise throughout the
meeting if any member has an interest to
declare please use the chat function
to indicate now and i'll invite them to
speak
anybody yes cancer fluke chairman
thank you chairman uh in the interests
of openness and transparency agenda five
i know the applicant agenda seven i know
the applicant
an agenda nine i know both the
applicants and the agent thank you
chairman
anybody else chairman just so you're
aware
counselor channel has a hand up thank
you
thank you thank you sorry yeah i did
no i did the chat as well so sorry i'm
just playing around with this a bit
um just to declare my normal one at the
moment chairman non
um sorry elected member of essex county
council
as well it's non-pecuniary and of course
they get consulted on
various things under their remit such as
highways access education
archaeological maybe etcetera chairman
thank you anybody else
yes yes can i i know the applicant
of number five sorry and that's
councillor hall isn't it
yeah that's councillor howell sorry okay
yeah
okay and then castle stamp would like to
speak as well please chairman
please chairman i'd just like to say in
my capacity
because everybody's declaring interest
so clearly as the mayor i have met
various people and applica people have
made applications on
today's agenda chairman can i just say
in future i really do not feel it's
necessary
um but i just wanted to cover myself for
today's meeting thank you chad yes
you've done it once and that should
suffice thank you very much councillor
stamp
anybody else
sorry sorry i was just saying there's
nobody else chairman
i well i will declare an interesting the
last last item
is councillor sue white mrs patton
she is a fellow councillor on the mulder
district council
thank you
[Music]
land adjacent three treadmills ham
ha farm steeple road southwestern
uh application 1901
335 stroke outline land adjacent thread
needles
farm super road south mister found on
pages 23-24
in a moment i will call on officers to
present this item
members are reminded that if you wish to
speak on this item please make this
known using check function
within this meeting i will then come to
you in turn please keep your points
clear and concise ms matthews will
report please
thank you chairman
so um an application for land adjacent
farm in
south midster the location of the
application site is indicated
on the um on the overhead there and it's
an application
to demolish the existing buildings and
the construction of new buildings
and to be divided into eight units um
business units for class b1
and or class b d1 uses
and this is an outline application with
all matters of detail reserved for
future determination this is a location
plan showing the application site
and it shows where the existing
buildings are right in the corner
and the the um the junction of steeple
road and scott hill
and all the other buildings that you can
see on that slide are
residential properties it's an aerial
view of the site
showing again those existing buildings
in the bottom right hand corner
the open storage and and the other uses
made of the um
area to the north the um
the aerial view is not up to date
because the the field
appears to be on the left and above the
site is
currently being developed um for
residential purposes
catherine we've had remember asking the
chat if you can move your mic so i think
there's a bit of feedback or something
okay i couldn't hear anything
i don't know it's noise of your breath i
think going into the mic if you
might need to move it away a bit okay is
that better
that's a lot quieter i'm going to say if
i move it away
some happy compromise is that okay
that's fine yeah i don't know i must
i don't know i had this problem before
um so we've got the
um i have to hold it out the way maybe
um so we've got existing elevations and
floor plans of the building that's on
site currently
um this is an outline application um
so all matters are reserved including
layout and access but this is an
indicative
block plan which submitted which
suggests that the buildings could be
located on the
southern boundary of the site and with
parking in the middle and then at
attenuation pond um
to the north with a new access along the
eastern boundary the site opposite crown
way
german council voice hasn't got a
picture sargent should
interrupt you he's got no picture
okay yeah i'm just checking what what
with caster boys what he's using
thank you
um counselor boys we've just checked on
the ipad and um
and it's viewing fine are you using your
an ipad or a laptop
at the moment cancer voice
i think council boys
having trouble sorry with uh with the um
i
ipad and the muting and unmuting
and i've just got a black screen
the ipad it wasn't it was all right to
start with but
it it just refuses to mute or
unmute uh and as i say i've got a black
screen so
i think it looks like i'm gonna have to
sit this one out and see if
it clears up if you could turn it maybe
just i mean i know it sounds ridiculous
but turn it off and turn it on again
because the ipad is working perfectly
viewing perfectly on this so well
not not here i've got i've got a little
photo of you and a little photo of
me down the right hand corner but that's
all
okay i'll i'll go out and try coming
back again again
chairman yeah and and berna
you may have picked it up i'm getting
messages as i think we all are that
there's a member in attendance i'm sorry
i was
fishing around with these um mute
headphones i heard things i didn't pick
that up
no well i've just i've just um responded
to councillor morris to say no to it
i've i'm i'm back and i've seen i've
i've now got the
indicative floor plan oh brilliant okay
that's where we're at
okay i think okay and i have
acknowledged the member in attendance so
we can carry on now
thank you all right miss matthew
shouldn't carry on
okay thank you um
sorry i'm just
okay so hopefully everyone can see their
um indicative floor plan
um and the um those indicative
elevations um so that the top one is
opposed north elevation
which would be the front of the building
but it would have the building would
have its back if you like to
scott's hill and that's the second
elevation there and then the two side
elevations
at the bottom and it listed drawings of
what the building might look like
and these are some photos of the site um
so those four photos show different um
angles of the existing buildings of the
site
and we got a photo there showing the new
housing being built in the background
and also a photo showing the um
or the area where the ashland brook is
located between the building and
scottsdale
okay so um the application is being
recommended for refusal
um because there are sites available in
the district as a whole where land falls
outside the highest
risk flood zone and where permission
could be obtained for employment
development
the development would therefore not
comply with the flood risk sequential
tests
and is not acceptable from a flood risk
perspective
the proposal is for a building with a
significantly greater for
floor space um and is indicated as being
two-story
building in the same visual visually
prominent position as that which exists
whilst the layer to the site and the
appearance the building proposed is
indicative a building with the amount of
floor space
proposed excuse me has the potential to
be of a
size heightened position which would be
visually incongruous within the street
scene to the detriment of the character
appearance of the area and it's
recommended that plan permission is
refused for these reasons
and just remember the information um i
did i did have
um a final slide um which is an extract
from the government
and website showing the flood risk zones
which
clearly shows the um almost the whole
site is um
as identified as being at risk of
flooding thank you chairman
thank you very much under the council
public participation
scheme we have received one submission
from the applicant
in line with public public participation
scheme
i have reviewed the submission and will
now read it out allocating two minutes
only
for reading in accordance with the
sorry chairman i had a blank black
screen for part of that your
announcement
and you've now pumped coming up popped
up again but i just had a blank
screen sorry that was still here that
was my fault
could you still hear the voice
could you still hear what was going on
counselor
probably just repeat that public
participation
bit because the screen was blank and it
was very hard to hear
under the council's public participation
scheme we have received one submission
from the applicant in line with public
participation scheme i reviewed the
submission and will now read it out
allocating two myths only
to reading in accordance with the
scheme submission is from
bradley faulkner we're very grateful to
be able to explain why we have spent so
much time and money on trying to find a
solution
for our small farm yard and buildings
unfortunately it's proving
more difficult to store our farm
machinery and equipment
as we have done for many years now that
the farm yard is
entirely surrounded by new houses and is
already causing upset
to the residents they do not wish to
hear tractors and equipment running
whilst that whilst we are attaching
implements and getting ready to leave
in the morning we've had several
occasions over the last year
received notices of alleged noise
complaint
which will only increase now that we
have encased in new houses
we also understand fully that is not
ideal
view from the bedroom window we really
feel that the proposed development would
be an
improvement for this tropical piece of
land and will allow
environment opportunities and local
facilities for the local people
who now feel after the last few months
that traveling to work is not something
they wish to do
in future does any other officer want to
say anything before i move to the
recommendation
the recommendation the planning
application 19 stroke
01 335 stroke outline
plan to change the threatening farm
steep road southeast
refuse for reasons that detail in
section 8 of the report
if any member wishes to second that
motion please turn on your video
i'll mute your michael and state your
name now
thank you um tell me how some speakers
please if you want to speak please
indicate
um i i'll second it chairman
okay i thought i must have this
microphone on mute still sorry
would there any members like to speak on
this please
yes counselor fluker would like to speak
thank you councillor
please carry on yeah thank you chairman
i noticed um i know that councillor
channel has seconded the
uh the the proposal to refuse this
application
chairman i i asked for this uh
application to come in
to uh committee and i and i certainly
sympathise with the
with the applicant because this is a
very difficult uh
uh site for all of the the reasons that
the
the officers the officer mentioned in
their report but chairman
the concern is is that members that have
known southminster for some
time we'll remember that the bali
meadows development on
on the other side of the road uh was
originally planned to be
industrial and it was something that the
the villages fought against for years
and eventually we overturned the
decision and allowed residential to be
there
and the reason behind that chairman was
because people didn't want to come into
southminster and see
uh commercial buildings and i know this
is only an outline application but i
think that reason is still there
and chairman there's also a massive
problem
that rather innocuous looking uh ditch
is actually ashwood and brook
and there's actually standing watering
at the moment
and it's causing residents a huge amount
of
concerning steeple road because of that
and what the likely effect of any other
development in that area is going to
have so i think chairman the officer's
recommendations and the reasons are
correct although i do i do sympathize
with the applicant and and the other
thing chairman i'd also say is
is that if if the officer could put the
proposed site plan back on
the uh up on the screen
can we do that please
yep oh um it's the proposed one
[Music]
it's the one missed message that shows
sort of steeple road and the
the uh the display that's an indicative
block plan
yes thank you mr johnson that's the time
i'm
worth out of my mouth then you did yeah
now we just need to find it my
computer's not um
hang on there we go thank you very much
so um i know this is what it was there
oh i haven't turned it off there we are
we're there now
yeah i've not got it i've got a blanket
no sorry
did you miss johnson did you share your
screen and share it if you want to do
that again if that was the case
yeah i was uh trying to come to the
rescue uh
you might need to do that again
yeah if we can ask mr johnson to come to
the rescue
please we'll let you know when we're
rescued
are you ready we are we are dutifully
rescued
right okay so remember steeple road
you'll remember that there is
a a large development now to the
uh the west and north of this uh which
is i think called blackwater reach which
is a development of around about 120
houses
but as part of that development coming
forward steeple road is going to be
blocked off
which means anybody ingressing and
accessing this site
is going to either have to come down
steeple road which is very very narrow
between the property called the cottage
and this application site
or turn left and go up crown way which
should mean all the traffic would have
to go through the village
or negotiate this very tight junction so
tim and i know
that highways um don't have
uh you know haven't commented on this as
such
but they need to be made aware chairman
should this application come forward in
the future
that steeple road is due to be blocked
off and that there will be no
access to the north um so chairman i
think
councillor stamp and uh i beg your
pardon councillor chana
and yourself have made a proposal based
on the office's recommendation
i'd ask it be put thank you
can you take a vote please on the
recommendation which is truly seconded
by counselor kenner
yes chairman i'm so voting for the
office's recommendation of refusal
i will call your name in alphabetical
order councillor bassinger
agreed which
side has to be cancer boys agreed
agree the recommendation to refuse
cancer fluka yes gentlemen with a heavy
heart agree the recommendation to refuse
answer helm
mr hall agreed
agreed
against
okay chairman that's um
six four one against one abstention
that's carried thank you very much we
move on to item six
uh former petty crows boat yard the quay
key burnham on crutch planning
application 20
treble 097 stroke 4.
please note a members update in relation
to the application has also been circled
circled prior to the meeting have you
all received that
to present this item remember as a
reminder that if you wish to speak on
this item please
make this known using the chat function
within the meeting i will then come in
you in turn please keep your points
clear and concise
miss henron please
thank you chairman uh hopefully you can
all see my screen
and this is a full application seeking
planning permission to demolish the
existing buildings within the site
and to wreck the building that would
consist of 75 elderly person apartments
and they'll also be vehicular and
pedestrian access car parking communal
facilities and community areas
so here we have the location plan and so
this is the sea
wall along the south of the site
belvedere road and the crimson yacht
club just to provide you with some
focal points um so before i go into
the plan details i just wanted to touch
on some points about the principle of
development
the application has been applied for as
a c2 residential institution
and has therefore been assessed on that
basis and but section 5.2 of the officer
report provides a in-depth assessment as
to whether the development would be a c2
use
based on the assessment in the report
it's um considered that there are a
number of factors that lead officers to
consider that development is
a c3 dwelling house or a sui generous
use opposed to the c2 use
so the factors that i'm referring to
things such as the
units would be fully self-contained
the um the
apartments would require one primary
resident to have a care need but that
would be set at a minimum of two hours
per week
and there's no assessment as to what
would happen if the individual care
requirements fell below those two hours
on that note so surviving partners would
have a right to stay in the
accommodation
which would ultimately remove the care
requirement
and some of the units would be available
in the open market and some for rent and
guidance suggests that c2 units are not
available on the open market
and many of the facilities provided
within the site which i'll show you
um despite the presentation fall outside
of the definition of
personal care also in relation to the
principle of development the site's
outside the settlement boundary
and it's not considered as anything
under the exceptions within policy s8
that would allow this type of
development because it's not considered
that
um given the level of facilities at the
site that it would be similar to a
community hospital
um allowed under policy eye too the
proposal would result in the loss of an
employment site which is protected under
policy e1 of the local plan
and is a primary related use protected
under policy ri
3 of the neighborhood plan
there has been some marketing submitted
in relation to the loss of employment
but
it's considered outdated as it dated um
six years ago
there um in relation to policy h3 which
is the one that you can see on your
screen
it um has been demonstrated that there's
denied
so it's not considered that there's been
um identified there's a
need for the type of development and
that the demand
identified in the shema for um c2 uses
have been exceeded through other
permissions in the district
therefore there's concern that
development could result in the inward
migration of older people
due to an over provision especially in
burnham town government guidance wants
older people housing to provide a
mixture of type and provision of tenure
to support people in their own homes
before they move to a c2 use which isn't
considered to be the case here
and given that there's a lack of
consideration of permission
at lan
or you may know it better as tinker's
hole and means that there's
possibly an over provision with burnham
within burnham for this type of
um development so c2 uses
okay then so that brings me on to the
plans
this is the block plan and see the roofs
of the buildings here
car parking piece would be um amenity
space
and immediacy space to the north
here we have the existing elevations and
floor plans and then you can see the
existing
street scene and the river view across
the bottom
these are the proposed ground uh first
floor plans
appreciate it's really hard to see on
that ground floor plan but
there's no living accommodation proposed
at ground floor uh this is where the
communal and operational facilities
would be there's
um along this part of the site here
there's um a cafe bar and restaurant
which would also be open to the public
um refuse within this area there's
bins in this part of the site and areas
for mobility scooters
then first floor would have um
the residential accommodation
second and third floors again um which
would all be
accommodation the
slightly smaller fourth floor or smaller
fourth floor
and roof plan
these are the proposed elevations uh so
the footprint
of the building is approximately 830
square meters greater
than the existing built form on the site
and would also be
10.7 metres greater in height and
this increase in built form is
considered to represent an
overly large development which wouldn't
be in keeping with the existing
landscape or the existing built form
within the settlement to the west
also to the east is the denji marshland
um the site itself is considered to play
an important role between the transition
of
the urban form of burnham town itself to
the the countryside beyond and
it's considered a building five stories
in height would disrupt this transition
uh so here we have some street scenes i
think this
further highlights the dominance of the
building within its setting
some illustrative drawings
and you can see the corinthian yacht
club in both of the
um images uh as i'm sure you're aware
it's a great two listed building
um but it's not considered that the pros
would demonstrably impact on the
heritage out there or the
nearby conservation area and that's
that there's still the concerns in
relation to the impacts on the carrots
and appearance of the area
and more illustrative drawings
so this shows that the site lies within
flood zone 3
the flood risk assessment concludes that
there are no other reasons
reasonably available sites but given
that as officers we believe there's an
undemonstrated need for the development
it's not considered the sequential test
has been passed
and in relation to exception tests the
flood management and evacuation plans
do provide sufficient measures to ensure
that development will be safe for its
lifetime
but the harm resulting from the
development such as the lack of
affordable housing contribution
and the impact of the character
appearance of the area means that there
are not
that there are limited community
benefits and so it's not considered
paragraph 160 of the mppf is complied
with
so here we have some photos of the site
you can see the access road on um
that joins belvedere road doesn't
include a footpath
and the local highway authority have
raised concerns into uh in relation to
the fact that
there's going to be more pedestrian use
of that area um
and the fact that the access serves a
caravan site and boatyard
as well as the application site that
there'll be conflicts with
um in the highway um
which we call safety issues for
pedestrians as the applicant doesn't
have control over this area
and it's not possible to control this
viral condition
and just some more photos of the site
and some up
from the sea wall so to summarize all of
that
the development is recommended for
refusal um for the following reasons
the site is located outside the
development boundary country to policy
s8
it's considered to be a contrived
development that results in material
harms the character and appearance of
the area
and would result in their unnecessary
visual intrusion
the loss of employment has not been
satisfactorily
um justified the development is
considered to fall within a c3 or sui
generous use class opposed to a c2
and so for that reason the development
doesn't make adequate provision for
affordable housing
it's not considered that it's been fully
demonstrated as need for the development
particularly in burnham due to the
impacts of other planning permissions
the details in the ecological appraisal
are
considered insufficient to ensure that
development would not adversely impact
on the existing ecological assets and
habitats within the site
and it is noted that there are benefits
to this scheme such as a provision of
specialist accommodation but given the
need for this type of development has
not been
sufficiently justified it's not
considered that the benefits would
be sufficient to outweigh the objections
and members are also reminded that there
was a members update which includes
further
letters of representation and amendment
to a typographical error within the
report
that's it for me thank you chairman
thank you very much miss hernan
we've received two public participation
submissions which i'll read now
um first one is from
rejector diane bailey former peter
crowe's boatyard the key
vernon von crouch cmo 880 planning
application 20
trevolo 97 stroke fol
75 specialists assisted elderly persons
living units to be read to
members at the fifth of august committee
meeting
to whom it may concern we're right to
voice
the extreme concern of local burnham
residents regarding the planning
application
the adopted bergamot crowds neighborhood
development plan is clear and specific
regarding new residential developments
and this lies within zone 3 flood plain
contravenes policy nhd1
and does not reflect either materials
form or scale of local buildings
policy nhd9
the application site lies out the
societal development boundary from the
town
an ample provision has already been made
for
local residents for elderly and care
accommodation
with the recent commission of burn
waters
and then in brackets carbuncle
development
emergency vehicles will impact on
already stretched roads and navigate
through the centre of burnham residents
frequently require frequent diagnosis
tests
and hospitals need to are over an hour
away
at broomfield for those requiring
ambulance this is
far from ideal vehicle access is a major
concern
all traffic serving this new isolated
site
must pass through a really really
congested town center
belvedere road in particular has long
been a danger point
and is a narrow blind 90 degree bend
where near accidents are happening every
day
this is highlighted where a current
minor gas
leak in the road is causing chaos
presence of both residential blocks
on the belvedere road pesicro keys and
the crow's nest have experienced serious
concerns
over road traffic where the road is
narrow and so close to their apartments
which face directly onto the road
likewise the corinthian
raw corinthian yacht club where younger
members are constantly crossing the road
adjacent to their dinghy park
many times each day buses turn at the
end of belvedere road calls and
tailbacks in both directions
burnham town council and consultation
have strongly objected
proposal sighting amongst other points
mdc's spatula vision
development strategy states that it is
appropriate to limit the level of growth
for birmingham crowd to meet its own
needs
we are already accommodating the major
within the birds and forces development
housing for specialist needs must be
spread across the district
the mold development plan specifically
attempts to retain commercial
use and employment wherever possible and
whilst boats
both buildings has ceased at this site
it could be developed as a single or
multiple small office units
which would be much better accommodated
on this site
the change of use proposed is
inappropriate despite claims of the
applicant
the vehicle of traffic serving the site
of 30 daily movements is frankly absurd
with elderly residents moving to and
from the hospital nursing care
deliveries and with online shopping
increasing
the real figure might be 10 that
far more than existing commercial use
it is widely understood that the burnham
structure is
already stretched to its absolute limit
access roads schools
healthcare and serious treatment the
adjacent treatment part is frequently
overloaded
resulting in foul smells through the
town with an easterly wind
the view from the river for visiting
yachtsmen and river users
returns to the the to the burnham is
iconic
the crayon at rice and coals boat yard
and the eastern wall of coral
cub are a welcome of familiar side
75 proposed apartments over five stories
will spoil this forever
proposed oversized and scaled building
so close to the river if allowed to
proceed
will be a travesty we urge most strongly
that members support the officer's
recommendation and fuse the scheme
thank you all right we've got to find
the next one there
right submission two from applicant mr
michael carpenter
dear members i address here in the
limited time available just
one of the key points made in the
planning office report concerning
meeting
the district-wide need for old people's
accommodation
in paragraph 5 113 the officer
contends that taking into account the
outline planning mission
at tinker's hole for 103 market
bungalows and a 70-bit care and 55
assisted living apartments which
includes 50 affordable housing units
and two further care homes planning
commissions close to tinker's hole
that burnham and molten road burnham and
within the
north heybridge garden suburbs the
demand for extra care
units identified within the shema has
already been exceeded
through these three permissions
highlighted above
this is not this is this is in fact
not the case firstly our proposal is not
a care home which provides an entirely
different
form of care and medical support
conditions and
tests 106 agreement clauses can be
imposed to ensure that
difference between the forms of c2 use
are maintained in person actually we
should
therefore be concerned only with the
proposed number of open market
assisted living or extra care units
proposed
but not yet with detailed consent of
tinker's hole
final calculation at tinker's hole will
depend upon the precise design
and restrictions placed on the proposed
market bungalows 103
and assisted living market department 5
the shma projects market requirement to
2018 for shelters and extra care units
amongst
to 258 best i think as whole
would produce an open market old
people's independent home
108 so leaving a residential requirement
of 150
in any event the demand referred to was
a demand projected
only to 2018 based on data
available in 2014. it is an undeniable
truth
recognised in the smart that the
population of molten districts
indeed nationally is aging with
increasing demand for care
for alternative firms of accommodation
if both development
would not be completed until 2022
so would be contributing towards meeting
an increased need
up to and beyond 2022
four years later the 2018 projection in
the smart and eight years are
later than the data collection point
but also worth reminding ourselves that
the smart assessment recognizes how
planning would need to be adapted to the
changing demands and the growth in new
forms of accommodation
paragraph 13 10 4
of the shmar reads this set this
sector an extra care sector
and other an older person's housing
market is relatively
new and the growth forecasting
population projects over
the next decade to 2021
but those days 75 plus years may well
increase the need for this type of
accommodation the demand may also
increase as understanding of this sector
of supporting houses increased
would any officers like to say anything
before putting the recommendation
right the recommendations report is as
follows the planning application 20
treble 0 9-7 stroke ful former
petticoat's boatyard the key burn on
crouch
be refused for the freezers as detailed
in section 8 of the report
any member wishes to second that motion
please turn on your video unlock your
marker and state your name now
i'll second next schemes big skins okay
uh thank you i now invite members to
make any comments on the report
yes we've got cancer skins and counselor
fluker
pass the skins please oh yes sir uh
thank you very much uh concerns of
course uh an agreement with the officers
on
concerns about how long this would be a
uh uh
a care home if it's possible to go in
there fee uh
rather ill and eating treatment and then
it becomes your home
so it does sound it does have that
feeling of being
uh more of a housing development really
or sort of a flat accommodation
development also of course all the
points about it being outside the uh
area for strategic development but most
important
can i ask in my mind anyway among the
many very good reasons
could i ask one of the officers to put
up the pictures of the first
illustrative drawings please
that's the first of the two
kevin can you do that please yep sorry
just trying to
get to the right
are we there yes exactly now
this is uh this illustrates the probably
the
one of the major local concerns uh you
look to the
uh historic and uh uh awarded uh
multiple awarded architecture of the
royal corinthian to the left in the top
picture
to the right the new development which
is dominant you look in the uh
picture below showing rice and coal's
boat yard
followed by this massive development
followed by the
diminutive um uh corinthian now of
course i realize this is a
partly a trick of perspective but the
point is this
some years ago more district council uh
in their wisdom or otherwise decided to
agree the development of burnham shores
to the
uh west of the town as you approach
along the sea wall and indeed this is
all visible from
as you come down the heist to the
station road too as you approach from
the west you see burnham shores and it
is massive it dominates the town
now the same is being proposed again
that we have a dominant
uh uh and similarly similar looking
facility
uh which will dwarf uh the town itself
as you approach
uh the town from the east along the sea
wall
i just think that's not acceptable uh i
just think
there's no way it can be that size
and indeed should be considerably
smaller even if it was to be approved in
any form
and that that is one of the many reasons
why
i think this is this proposal cannot be
supported
thank you hey cass against caster fluker
please
chairman i just wanted to raise a couple
of points but one thing i wanted to ask
mr lee is what sort of impact is this
likely to have
on our five-year land supply bearing in
mind this confusion over c2
through chairman um as the applicant has
submitted an
application it informs that c2 and if
the council is to agree that then it
wouldn't impact on our five-year land
spy in a positive way if that makes
sense because
it's an unallocated site so normally if
it was for dwellings it would be classed
as a windfall but as c2 it doesn't
benefit that in any way
thank you chairman yeah thank you jeff
if i could uh if i could just come back
with some of my comments
i mean looking at i mean members will
remember i mean i i i can remember when
the fair club
fair club homes development was built i
remember the old pmp new
pe and petticoats as well and i'm i'm
sure councillor schemes will as well as
a six-year-old as he always reminds us
but
um but if you look at that development
if you can see
what petticrow's keys is is the white
building
a bigger pattern it's it's the the
building with the the red roof and
there's like a
a white uh gable can you just point at
that devon
up a bit no no up a bit that's it left a
bit
no no no left of it stop that's the
white cable
well that piece of land from the the
cursor through to what looks like this
proposed dead development
um did have planning permission on to
extend petty cross keys
and the whole idea of pedigree's keys
was when that was approved was it was
low
it sat down below the corinthian it sat
below the sea wall
and officially at the time that was
quite acceptable but
fairclough homes i think disappeared
into something else and that the second
part of that development never came
forward
um chairman i i accept there is a
conflict with c2 i accept that this is
outside the settlement boundary
and and i think it's a long time since
we've had such a
robust objections from uh highways
um chairman i know d1 is very subjective
but i agree totally what councillor
skins is saying
with regards to what that looks like i
mean so many water fancy
fun so many waterfronts in essex have
been devastated i mean
with and hoe is a classic example uh
and i think that this really does not
fit in but
chairman the other thing that concerns
me enormously is this is for 75
apartments now worst case scenario
chairman that could be
150 people living on this site
the 106 contribution based on this
application to the national health
service to the local gp surgery
is 17 664 pounds german
and that equates to 117 pounds
and 50 pence per occupant if two people
live in each of these flats
i know that this is a an nhs
algorithm but this is wholly
inappropriate
um i was speaking to the the the surgery
the other day chairman
and they really don't have any capacity
so
i don't think that is appropriate that
level of funding
but overall chairman i think that uh
this
this application uh is proposed that
it's refused and i think in its current
form
and i think that's what maybe councillor
schemes is alluding to
in its current form um it should be
refused
but there may be in the future chairman
something else that's more appropriate
on that site
but this isn't it thank you thank you
did cancel the voice want to speak or
did his screen go
no he thought it's sorted now but
council stand would like to speak
german thank you chairman uh thank you
members
and i actually have a little bit of
sympathy for this applicant
i actually noticed um that obviously it
is in breach of
s8 outside the development boundary but
we all know carbuncle at the top which
is referred to as tinker tinker's hull
was exactly the same
they also paid nhs contributions which
is what
councillor fluke has just raised that is
a formula not set by the council
we can't do anything about that i also
noticed that the
highways actually did put a report and i
was quite surprised because normally
on smaller applications they don't even
bother um
i actually am very disappointed in the
fact that this final presentation and
this drawing is being put forward
because this
um developer has visited the town
council offices on numerous occasions
with different
aspects and we always said at our
council we didn't want such a high
building on the front and they did a
proposal or one of their
um proposals was to move it so it wasn't
so high
we actually did say to the developer
please don't have it so high
council schemes was absolutely right we
hated
uh the um previous it's like a book end
you have this you got it this end and
the other end um which is the lc first
site to me it's like a book end you're
closing
in the key of burnham but i do have
sympathy
to be quite honest with you i could
think of nothing better
than in my retirement which i am
eligible
to go onto this site if it was building
not proud to say that
to actually look over our beautiful
river but i also share the concerns
of our residents and i also chairman if
you'll allow me
really wanted this application to go to
full council
um i think it's a it's it's to do with
the whole of the district
um being able to um you know have they
fit the criteria for elder people's
housing whether it be c2
or c3 and i did really really want it to
go but council fluker and the planning
officers
said that it couldn't do because it
didn't fit the criteria but i know
you've put a motion
but i'd like to put a motion forward
that we actually do defer this
to gather more information because there
is some information
from statutory consultees who haven't
replied
and the officer presentation was
brilliant she actually
highlighted everything that was you know
lacking which is the ecology report
let's not forget nobody's actually
mentioned that essex county council
who didn't support the carbuncle is
supporting
this one so you know i hope members did
read this
huge report because it was excellently
put together and devon has
actually come back with some separate
queries that i had but i would like to
propose i know i won't get it seconded
that it is deferred to go back to the
statutes council tease
or like cl councillor fluke would turn
around and said to try and mitigate put
some different changes in
that may be acceptable i'm not saying it
is i'm not saying it isn't
and also for it to go to full council
district planning
thank you chairman thank you we have
we've got a second
for that proposal uh well caster fluka
would like to come back will accept that
being you were mentioned
and chairman i don't want to come back
on that proposal but
so i don't know if you put your question
i wanted to come back on something else
german thank you
right do you want to come back or not
well okay i'll come back but i thought
first of all you were going to wait for
a second to cancel the stamps but i mean
tell me
so chairman i i really just you know for
clarity
you know these two uh burnham walters
and this development are completely
they are completely different and the
berlin walters development i think
brings forward you know
a medical center and all sorts of things
so it is quite different their
contribution
but i i did notice chairman in this
report that the town council objects to
to this
and it's contrary to the burn and plan
we've had but
kevin i think the message here is rather
than deferring this
i mean i'm sure i'm sure this is the
beauty of these meetings i'm sure that
there'll be lots of people here
lots of people listening in the
background to what's being said
and and there's absolutely no reason
german why they can't go back come back
with a second go
um i think the members have made a you
know some very valid
points particularly about height and
size and scale and who knows
they uh the you know i can't help
laughing at what someone's just put on
chat
um but who knows chairman they might
come back with something completely
different that we like
and who knows tim and they might come
back with a very exclusive development
looking over the river
which you know looks more like petticoat
keys but i'll park it there chairman
i'll ask you
first question
can i can i please come back on that
because burnham town council yes
did but i'm an independent person and i
look at the fact
so i'm allowed to say what the view i
have thank you yeah you have
you have said that that's perfectly
satisfactory you haven't
you haven't got a second so we'll move
to the main recommendation that refusal
uh secondly by councillor skis i believe
berna can you take the vote please
yes so we're voting for the officer's
recommendation counselor passenger
agrees
council council boys
um um agreed
um cancer channel dropped out for for a
while in that discussion
i just wanted to check um
um chairman i lost contact
uh for part of the time you were
speaking when you were delivering quite
a long
message so i've indicated i'm not going
to be voting i don't want it shown as
abstention i don't want it shown as
agree or against i want it shown that
i'm
due to losing contact i feel i can't
vote
thank you very much we'll move on please
thank you very much
uh councillor fluker yeah um i think
councillor channel you just do what i
did the other day and declare on the
wall 5.7 of the virtual meetings
procedures
um german as far as recommendation uh i
agree the officer's recommendation thank
you
house to helm great
members that's uh
six for uh none against one abstention
thank you very much for that i now move
on to item
seven planning application twenty double
o
four o four slash fuel density homeless
sports center
bernalillo approach found on pages 99
to 108. and the moment our last offices
are foreign members a reminder that if
you wish to chat
speak on this item please make it be
known using the chat function within the
meeting
i will then ask you to come forward
please make the points
clear and concise thank you very much
mistakers thank you chairman
this application seeks planning
permission for the installation of
four eight metre high lighting poles
which will be used to illuminate the
sports field for rugby training sessions
between five and nine on mondays to
thursdays
it's noted that the polls are currently
in place
uh this is the location plan um showing
the
whole playing field here in relation to
the sports center site and then this is
the area to the north where the lights
will be located
um the block plan just showing um a more
close-up view of where the four
lighting poles will be located and the
lighting will
shine towards the playing fields to the
south and not
shine towards any of the neighboring
properties to the north
the elevations of the lighting
an example of the proposed lighting
heads to be used
some photographs showing some views
within the site
and these are the views um south towards
the playing fields
um north east you can see the sports
center here and then the playing field
here
and then this view to the north where
the lights would be located
you can just see some of the neighboring
properties to the rear
and these photographs show um some of
the existing lighting that's already
on the site and then this is one of the
polls that's already been put in place
apologies sorry apologies to a man could
we just check and see if we can get
cancer boys to scream back
just we could just pause for a minute
yes that's fine
[Music]
um he's saying he's going to have to
leave the meeting okay thank you very
much
okay so i'll just say notice and we'll
carry on with the presentation thank you
very much right okay and then yes these
photos just show the sports center here
and then some of the neighboring
properties to the north
here so overall subject to um conditions
regarding the positioning
timing use and luminescence of the
lighting the proposal can be found
acceptable as it complies with the ldp
and is therefore recommended for
approval thank you chairman
thank you very much we have received one
public participation submission from the
applicant
which i'll now read the act mr neil
hornet this is a statement on behalf
of burnham on crouch record club
committee members
thank you for taking the time to
consider our planning application for
additional flood lighting
at the millfield site our club has been
in existence for over 50 years and
provides a significant
outlet for sporting activities in burn
and the surrounding villages we have in
excess of 200 children ranging
from ages 3 to 17 are participating
weekly sporting activities
as well as active senior members our
senior
men's team ladies team and a vets team
as the club numbers have grown
so is the demand for training facilities
to improve the standard
and coaching of the sides this has led
to considerable pressure on the single
training pitch
and whilst maintenance work has been
done to improve the drainage
the constant use inevitably renders part
of the pitch unusable
through constant use last season we lost
around six weeks of training due to the
waterlogged and unplayable conditions by
agreeing to the planning application
this will allow the club to use more of
the land spreading
the use across the gracie area and will
hopefully result
in training sessions being able to take
place without the need
to cancel with so much active sport
haven't been cancelled due to the
pandemic
it is important that as restrictions
slowly get lifted
we're able to provide an active outlet
for everyone to participate in the sport
and improve both their physical and
mental well-being
thanks for your time you're sincerely
neil hornet chairman
burnham sports club chairman burnham
roberts club
offices do you want to say anything more
before we move on
now recommendation the planning
application 2004
oh for ful dangerous sports center burn
montreal
be approved such conditions are detailed
in section 8 of the report
if any member wishes to second that
motion second indeed
councillor stamp seconded well i haven't
finished yet cancer stance
counselor what
you wish to speak secondary sorry i was
quick off the mark okay radio okay does
anyone want to speak
yes caster skins and cancer stamp
right cancel schemes first and then
cancel the stamp
yes obviously any concern with lighting
especially in the winter months which is
where it's likely to be most useful
uh is there is a concern about light
pollution
as a keen uh amateur astronomer uh
living on a houseboat south of this site
uh it is going to affect my
um well occasionally when the nights are
clear
that certainly will have an impact and
anybody living
south of that site and that is really as
far as i can see only the houseboats
will be affected to some uh
point but this is uh encouraging
exercise
and rugby in particular is strikes me as
a
extremely worthy cause and uh i cannot
find it in my heart to object to this
uh uh for any reason uh i think it's a
really good thing and it has my support
caster scans do you wish to
declare an interest being you mentioned
astronomy and the light would affect you
um well that's interesting i suppose i
could accept that i'm i'm not actually
voting uh against it so i mean yes i
suppose i have
an interest it's not pecuniary thank you
very much
i'm supporting it soon
um yes i think it's fantastic i think we
should be investing in our sports
facilities down in the town and for
people who actually go down to the rugby
club on a sunday morning when they've
got
it's the time of year for the rugby
season the atmosphere
along the sea wall and all the uh
riverside park it's absolutely fantastic
and i think it should be we should
commend them for putting so much effort
and investment not just in money but
also in time
to our community and i wholeheartedly
support it they work hundreds of hours
tirelessly for the community and the and
the dengue it's not just burnham
it's the dengue as well thank you
chairman you're here
anybody else counselor hull would like
to speak
to help please yes i agree with
councillor stamp
it's a very good idea and especially is
um the virus is about we've got to keep
fitter
it's ideal thank you anybody else
uh counselor sorry council fluke
sorry i didn't pick that up counselor
fluker i thought it was a message to
count
to cancer boys
the message was about artificial
intelligence but at 147 i think i did
actually ask to speak after the ward
members so we got there
and yeah i was just um i was just going
to
uh you know basically repeat what
counselor
uh stamp said because i know that neil
maher is here
listening to this meeting and probably
others and they've done a brilliant job
over the last
25 years with the rugby football club so
well done to them if they're listening
um just one thing for me and matt lee i
bet
mr lee will probably be able to answer
this i don't have any problems with this
plan
application but members will know that
we've had a lot of problems with flood
lighting at
malden tennis club and the uh the river
blackwater vessels using the river
blackwater
so i just want to be sure i know this is
somewhere in shore from the river
but i just wanted to make sure mr lee
that we can if there is a problem with
boats using
the river at night time and the light
pollution that we can make sure these
lights are kept low
thank you anybody else
i'd like to ask one question please the
picture of the two lights
they look to both the led lights and one
has a sensor on it is that to come on
when it's dark or when someone
approaches
does anyone know
my understanding is that they're only
turned on when they're you when they're
being used by training but maybe
advice thank you very much we'll move to
the hole
louise did you want to say something no
she's gone
right we'll move the german side to to
interrupt you i just wanted to make sure
louise is back she maybe she's going to
answer ask my question that i've got to
mr lee
you know we just want to make sure that
we can control this the light pollution
with regards to the boats that are used
in the river
in particular ships because it is
important i presume they'll do
everything they possibly can but we just
want to make sure we can control this
chairman
would you like to declare an interest
because you have a boat it might affect
your boat
um chairman i actually mentioned the
ship
okay his money's
can we have an answer about these lights
and whether or not we've got enough in
these uh
in these conditions to control them just
in case there's mr lee oh hi mr lee
thank you chairman
um um as council focused once we've
imposed or declined permission with the
conditions we wouldn't be able to
retrospectively
deal with any issues that arise unless
there was some sort of control through
the condition
that allowed that none of the conditions
suggested suggest
any way of reviewing that but i don't
think that's an issue because i think
the conditions are very
well covered at ensuring that the light
is directed at the pitches and
should ensure that there isn't a wider
spread um
so i don't think there should be an
issue now thank you chairman
thank you thank you is everyone finished
no can i come back
please chair just just that i think
because
you know the rugby club are very
conscientious
and if there was an issue that actually
transpired or came up a later date i'm
sure that they would discuss it with
molden district council
and come to a perfectly amicable
resolution so if something has been
overlooked
in total innocence i'm sure that the
committee will meet with you to make
sure it's okay for the burnham
thanks chairman okay thank you council
hull did you want to say something
no no she just still let her hand up but
cancer
yeah just uh to respond to counselor
fluker's comments
i think it highly unlikely that ships
coming up the river on the far
southern bank would be affected by uh
flood lighting on
uh on the riverside park uh there's
already a very
bright light that is on pretty much
permanently uh
to the um west of riverside park up on
the car park there by the marina
uh these are as i understand it and
maybe uh
uh an officer can confirm that these
lights only come on when training
sessions
are in play and if you're on uh
navigating a ship
down the uh up the channel towards
bamberg
or the balta's baltic wharf you're going
to be concentrating on what's ahead of
you
and to your right they're all the lights
of the town and i can't really see how
this would interfere
seconded by
can you take the vote please yes members
i will call you in alphabetical order um
for the officer's recommendation to
approve
counselor passenger approve
the channel approve
the fluke
[Music]
council
recommendation chairman none against no
extensions
thank you very much burner item eight
has been withdrawn we moved to item nine
land north
west of really nipsey's chase mainland
application
200 double o five four five seven four
slash
ful now found on pages one two one two
one two eight
terminology chairman i'll declare
non-pecuniary i know the applicant as
well obviously for
likewise anybody else
i think we all know the applicant shall
we take it everybody knows counsellor
yes okay right please note a member's
update in relation to this application
has also been circulated
prior to the meeting in a moment i will
call an officer to present the side to
members
a reminder that if you to speak on this
item please make this known
by using the chat function within this
meeting i will then come you into
in turn please keep your points clear
and concise and to the point thank you
very much
can you put your sound on please
apologies for talking to myself all
right
thank you this application is a
variation
of condition application and seeks to
amend the plans for a permission that
allowed
the erection of an apple storage barn do
the changes relate to alterations to the
windows and doors
and also and the plans show a brick dump
course opposed to the building being
fully finished in timber
the matter relating to the brick is
addressing the members update
so here we have the location plan this
site is located to the use of nipples
chase
the block plan that shows the sighting
of the barn which
has already been approved
these are the previously approved
elevations and floor plan
the proposed elevations so you can see
some additional windows
and openings
the revised floor plan
and some photos of the site
and some more photos so the alterations
do
result in the development appearing more
residential in nature than when it was
previously approved
and it's not believed that it's
reflective of its agricultural use
but it's noted that the previously
approved design was also not
reflective of the function of the
building and was also a residential
appearance as well so
on balance given that the alterations
don't alter the overall character of the
building in comparison to what was
previously approved
officers don't have any objection the
development is also considered
acceptable in all other respects
and so it's recommended for approval
subjects to the conditions in the report
thank you chairman thank you very much
the recommendation for this application
is to approve
uh could i if any member wishes to
second that motion please turn on your
video and
your microphone and state your name now
anybody i'll second it
thank you
uh anyone want to speak on this
application
yes counselor stamp how's the stamp
uh thank you chairman um i don't have a
massive problem with it at all but i
just wondered if anybody can answer the
question
why why do we need the windows in an
apple store is it to make them ripe and
quicker chairman do you know i didn't
have time to google
that point does anybody know why it
needs to be changed i can't tell you
i'm not an apple expert maybe some of
the penny officers can tell you
thank you i better remember will we
yes maybe that's what i'm hoping
thank you chairman and so the
application hasn't actually been
supported by
any information as to why the additional
windows would be needed
but given that the principle of
development was already established
through their previous permission
um and that bit was not for sort of
revisiting as part of this application
it's not um
it's not been assessed in that way if
that makes sense
it does and you know thank you for that
because i did read the report and i did
understand that i just wondered if
for a reason why they suddenly want to
change the windows when the application
looked perfectly fine
as i said i don't have a problem with it
it's more of a you know why do you want
to put windows in an apple store but
anyway thank you chairman
no answer
okay anyone else no chairman
we'll move to the recommendation second
by councillor hull
bernard would you like to take the vote
please
thank you chairman for the officer's
recommendation of approval
uh councillor passenger abstain
council channel approve
council
[Music]
stamp um i um afford it
thank you that's five for the officer's
recommendation none against and two
abstentions
that's carried thank you very much
bernard any other items of business that
the chairman declares are urgent
just that a couple of members couldn't
attend the meeting today
because they work that's all there is to
it uh
thank you members for your contribution
this afternoon i now draw the close the
meeting at
14 17 as the meeting is now closed
member advised not to enter in any
further discussion on this forum
and please leave the meeting think
promptly thank you very much
goodbye thank you